seven member states to agree on this
proposal but the main topic is the fact
that U this proposal agreed firmly
supported by 26 member states is a very
well balanced proposal on the one hand
this is a translation of a firm
commitment confirmed yesterday by 26
member states to support Ukraine with an
additional package of 50 billion EUR
it's a clear message a clear promise
support it firmly I repeat again by 26
member states point1 but this package
takes into account some very important
priorities for all of us at the European
Union's level migration solidarity fund
or defense for instance and also the
importance to pay the interest that you
need to pay because of our choices to
invest together in a common future
that's why I would like to repeat again
that I'm extremely confident and
Optimist that we will be in a position
to fulfill on our Pro misses to support
Ukraine with financial means uh in the
weeks to come I'm confident that the
decision will be
formalized
SEC is is
inter
human
[Music]
Pedro dear Pedro I would like to to
thank you and to thank your team the
Spanish team for the huge efforts for uh
this great Spanish presidency it was and
it is a real pleasure to work with you
to cooperate with you to cooperate with
your team and is impressive all what you
have achieved in the recent weeks and
months but I know that you will have uh
some difficult topics on the agenda for
next week you can count on us to support
and to continue to work with you and
with your
team thank you president president of
the European commission you have the
floor thank you very much um I would
like to start with a big thank you to
you prime minister Pedro for and I would
like to thank the Spanish team that has
been working so tirelessly on this
excellent Spanish presidency um over the
last uh six months thanks to your
dedication and to your commitment I
think we brought a large number of key
files past the Finish Line some of them
are crucial for our future economic
competitiveness just take for example
the the artificial intelligence act that
has been agreed last week after a
marathon trialogue it will allow Europe
to develop artificial intelligence that
people can trust so it strikes the fine
balance between security and Innovation
potential that is in lies in uh
artificial intelligence or take the
critical raw materials act that has also
been agreed under your
presidency with it you Europe will power
the glean clean energy transition with
secure and sustainable raw material
supplies it is of utmost importance for
us that we strengthen our supply uh
chains for raw materials because they
are crucial inputs for the digital and
the green transition you also made good
progress on the net zero industry act
now it will be for the Belgian
presidency to take this work forward so
congratulation on an impressive work I
counted over 50 political agreements
that have been reached and I want to
mention a last big big file where great
progress has been made that is the pack
of migration and Asylum here we aim for
political agreement on the pack by the
end of this year so this would complete
the extraordinary track record of this
presidency now this presidency ends and
the new year year starts with excellent
news for the European Union and our
neighborhood and friends because of uh
yesterday's decision the European
Council took the decision uh to Grant an
enlargement steps forward and this will
be a landmark in our common history we
have decided to open accession
negotiations with Ukraine and with mova
we have decided to grant Georgia the
candidate country status we have decided
to open accession negotiations with
Bosnia and heroa once the necessary
degree of compliance with the membership
criteria is achieved and we have
strongly reiterated our Collective
commitment to a future where all six
Western Balkan partners are part of our
Union for example for Albania and North
Macedonia the commission's objective is
to open accession negotiations on the
first so so called fundamentals clusters
as soon as possible the attempt is to
reach that goal next
week I think that yesterday's decisions
show that the European Union is living
up to its promise the reason for
enlargement
today um these reasons have never been
stronger and more
compelling in a world that is shaken by
multiple crisis it's an investment in
stability it's an investment in security
of our continent but of course it's also
an investment in prosperity for our
continent and it's a big investment in
democracies that stands St tall and
United let me now turn to the revision
of the EU multiannual
budget as you know the current budget
was designed right before the numerous
crisis we have encountered since its
adoption it was designed before the
pandemic
before Russia's war in Ukraine before
the severe energy crisis and the
inflation that this energy crisis
sparked it was of course designed before
the Middle East crisis not to speak of
the ever increasing number of natural
disasters that we are uh
witnessing so we have extensively
mobilized our EU budget to provide the
necessary support and answers but
we have now come to the limits of our
budget to answer these unexpected crises
and that is the reason why back in June
the commission proposed a
reinforcement of the EU budget we put
forward very clear
priorities of course the first priority
is Ukraine the support to Ukraine then
the work on
migration the Boost of Europe's
competitiveness our answer to the
inflation reduction act for
example we also ask for a topup to deal
with natural disasters and humanitarian
crisis and finally we need to adapt the
budget to increasing interest rates Now
26 member states confirmed those key
priorities and agreed to provide
additional financing to meet them I
wholeheartedly thank them for their
support this is a good good
result the agreement also addresses the
concerns of the member states related to
their National budgetary
constraints and thus the agreement
includes
redeployments and
reprioritization alongside new funding
and you can imagine that this
combination redeployment and new funding
required tough choices we have taken
those
choices However unfortunately we did not
managed to reach unanimity yesterday
Hungary was unable to support so there
is now a new Rendevous early next year
and we will use as a commission the time
until then to ensure that whatever
happens at this next Yuko we will have
an operational
solution finally let me briefly turn to
our discussion on the situation in the
Middle East both sides have to do their
utmost to protect protect civilian lives
and Hamas has to release all hostages
unconditionally the commission's
immediate priority is to deliver as much
humanitarian Aid to the Gaza Strip as
possible by the end of today team Europe
will have organized 28 humanitarian
airbridge flights altogether those
flights will have delivered around 1,200
tons of Aid and we are still planning
another five flights before the end of
the
year in addition to emergency aid indeed
we must also try to work on the day
after there can be no peace unless there
is the prospect of a political solution
both for Israelis and Palestinians and
this is the two-state solution there has
been a growing consensus on principles
to guide our work there can be no forc
displacement of Palestinians from Gaza
Gaza cannot be a safe heaven for Hamas
Hamas cannot be in the governance
structure of a Palestinian State a
reformed Palestinian Authority must
govern in the council over recent days
you'll remember that the first point
enlargement well on the 1 of July I was
I had the opportunity to go to keev and
meet at president zilinski and convey to
him the fact that uh all member states
and Community EU institutions are cly
resolved over the coming 6 months as it
was then to be able to reach the
historic agree agreement that we
achieved yesterday that is to open up
negotiations with Ukraine and not just
Ukraine but mova as well and of course
uh the same goes for the Western Balkans
and Georgia in
particular if they comply with the
necessary conditions that is and uh so
that was the commitment that we made on
the 1 of July in keev
on behalf of all the European Union
institutions and
Spain and this is just one of the
historic uh chances really it just so
happened that the opening of the
negotiations to include Ukraine was
approved under the Spanish
presidency um Spain is not a founding
member of the European
Union uh we joined back in the
80s and of course that it's an even
greater honor that being the case
because it's not so much only in in it's
not that the historical situation is the
same but there were many countries who
wanted to join the European family for a
long time and
ultimately it is possible for that to
happen with the backing and assistance
of the European Union institutions on
the multiannual framework Financial
framework as Shad said I believe that
over the past six months we've done some
work which has been very difficult very
complicated
it's really been quite painstaking but I
think we have managed to achieve one
significant thing we reached a agreement
among the 26 countries there are 27 of
us in the EU and I'm confident that
under the Belgian presidency over the
coming six months it will be possible
that uh prime minister de will be able
to achieve that agreement among the 27
I'm not sure whether it'll be easier or
more difficult than reaching agreement
among the 26 but in any event it will be
up to
him to
bring about this very necessary update
and revision of the mff as has already
been pointed out I don't really want to
say any more over and above what charl
has said I just like to thank all the
member states for their support and I
would just add to what the president of
the council said just one point which I
think was broadly accepted by the member
states namely this it's important that
the council reflects strategically on
the southern neighborhood it's clearly
apparent
that we've had other geopolitical
debates but I believe looking at what's
happening in the Middle East and not
only in the Middle East I think that
should compel us to look to the South as
well and to have a far more strategic
vision of what we're doing in the
European Union working together with
many countries who are our allies when
it comes to ensuring stability and
economic stability in in a very
important area namely the Mediterranean
a very important part of Europe and as
um as in my capacity as prime minister
of the med of a Mediterranean country
namely Spain that's extremely important
I think we've managed to conclude on
very important files both in
quantitative and qualitative terms and
I'd remind you that since the beginning
of Putin's war in Ukraine or even
beforehand we were beginning to feel in
the pockets of our Industries and
households in Europe we were feeling the
consequences of the increase in Energy
prices gas and electricity P
prices and it had an impact on our
family's purchasing power and on
Europe's competitiveness as well and
what we've been able to do over the past
few years few days is to reform the
energy Market it required very
thoroughgoing intense
debates it involved a lot of discussion
over many years as well and I think that
was one of the most important
achievements of this presidency and the
same goes for um the environment uh
critical raw materials uh and the
legislation on artificial intellig
and looking at it from a particularly
Spanish point of view I would remind you
of the important Summit that we held in
July here in
Brussels with our allies from Latin
America and the Caribbean the silac
summit that is where not only did we
commit to a number of strategic
investments in the Latin American and
Caribbean continent but we also
undertook to finance the and to to
Foster the Strategic relationship
between the two blocks that I believe is
very
important because clearly these trade
agreements uh have uh made some progress
obviously we would have wished to be
able to complete on mercosur but we
didn't manage to do that but we did
nonetheless sign an important agreement
with Chile which I'm sure will reaffirm
and Shore up this relationship the I'd
Al also just like to mention the
informal uh Council the informal Summit
that we held in Granada where we looked
at all the important points on Europe IC
agenda which will be taken forward under
the Belgian presidency so what we have
yet to do what lies ahead of us as the
president of the commission said I think
the immigration and Asylum pact is
extremely important then there a very
important meeting of finance and economy
ministers the aim being to reach
agreement on economic governance I think
that's highly relevant it's very
important that next year we are able to
introduce new fiscal rules and New
Economic
governance and lastly
particularly bearing in mind that in
Spain um it's very important to bear in
mind that um Romania is very important
indeed as is Bulgarian and we hope to be
able to ensure that by the end of the
year we can enable them to join to the
shenan area so I think that takes stock
of what we've done in the course of our
presidency and could I end where I began
I'd just like to thank all the public
officials and civil servants sometimes
we inclined to forget just how important
the role that they play just how
professional and committed they are to
the European Cause and fortunately this
applies to the Spanish Embassy the EU
institutions both the council and the
commission so dear sh oela um you've
really done an excellent job of work and
I'd like to thank everyone who was
involved including those who work in the
council and the commission with
questions then we go with
hor
um here valo with Bloomberg um two
questions for president Michelle first
um there were some leaders and
delegations that appointed that the
summit will be the extraordinary Summit
will be in late January you say early
next year if necessary that Summit could
be in February uh for president wonder
liion do you think that uh in basting
your contacts with the with Hungary do
you think that by then by that Summit
Hungary could conclude all the
outstanding 23
Milestones um to unblock the 20 billion
euros and you also mention uh that but
that time you will use that time to have
an operational solution does that mean
that by then you will have a plan B
ready in case there is no agreement at
27 on the mff thank you very
much
on your first question the special
Summit that will take place at the
beginning of the next year doesn't have
a date yet it will be around the end of
January beginning of February that's
just an indication that I can give you
but date not been confirmed yet yeah
okay so um first of all
um there are um three elements uh what
the blocked finances um the the blocked
budget parts for Hungary are concerned
the first one is Next Generation EU
everyone knows that next Generation EU
has a combination Investments for
reforms if Hungary moves on the
Milestones then there is a movement
forward with uh the payments as every
other member State also gets the
payments with the reforms the second
element is uh the conditionality
mechanism here too if Hungary fulfills
the requirements there's movement and
money could be dispersed and the third
element is uh the enabling conditions
for the cohesion funds here Hungary has
moved and the result is that 10 billion
um of cohesion funds were um are ready
to be dispersed uh with the typical
procedures of the cohesion funds so it's
always the same principle all the other
member states know these principles and
abide to these rules uh the Investments
come with the reforms and the moment
there is a delivery of the ne Neary
reforms there is a
dispersement um to the second part of
your questions we are working very hard
of course to have a uh result uh of
where there's an agreement of 27 member
states but I think it is now also
necessary to work um on potential
alternatives to have an operational
solution in case that a an agreement by
27 so unanimity is not possible
go with Maria next
Bas hi thank you very much I will take
the opportunity to to ask you in
Spanish
um it's a question for all three of you
really I'd like to ask about
Ukraine I'm wondering whether you're
concerned that you could awaken false
hopes as with the case with turkey and
the Western Balkans who've been on the
waiting list for years now and in view
of the tragedy of the war in in Ukraine
I'm wondering whether they could end up
being disappointed with the European
Union and that this question is or for
all three of you in particular prime
minister Sanchez in Strasburg there was
a very tough debate involving the leader
of the par popular in in in Europe
there's been a lot of talk about about
the amnesty and I think that this uh may
be tarnishing the image of the Spanish
presidency and your own image as a
European
leader and president Michelle and
president felion as well I'd like to ask
whether you think that's the case and
whether you think that all these rumors
and all the Electoral stir that's taken
place in Spain has disrupted the balance
in any
way shall I
start
well as regards how other people
perceive me there's not much of a view
that I can really have on that how I'm
perceived but I I would recall something
that I think is important in the
European Parliament context first of all
I think it's a mistake it's an error to
crti criticize uh Progressive European
minded governments such as ours by
fostering um facius uh statements
perpetrated by the opposition I mean
this is something that the European
people's party did say I know that this
point was made by Donald trusk before he
was elected prime minister of of Poland
that um the trouble is people can start
thinking in a certain way it's if that's
what they keep on being
told president sha Michelle on two
points first of all you were asking
about Ukraine and the fact that we could
awaken false expectations I think the
very opposite is the case I think what
we've just done is to take decisions
which will give people great hope but
they will also make it clear that there
is responsibility on both sides on
Ukraine's and Europe's side and so we
now have a two-fold duty you Ukraine has
a duty to be very committed and continue
the work in implementing the necessary
reforms in order to ensure that Ukraine
is able to join the political area the
space which is based on common values
and the legal space the legal area which
it shares with the European Union and we
have a
responsibility among the 27 member
states we need to prepare for that that
time the time of enlargement so once
again I am absolutely convinced
personally that this enlargement is a
choice it's a choice for the future of
Europe which in the future will need to
be more stable more safe and secure and
more prosperous and for our children I
think it needs to be more stable more
secure more prosperous with countries
who wish to join us within the European
Union and that applies to the Eastern
partnership and the Western Balan
countries too on my SEC on your second
point I don't have much to add merely to
re iterate self-evident truths the
European project is based on uh truth
and sovereignty of member states that's
the first point it's based on trust in
the Democratic institutions of the
member states and I think it's always
regrettable whenever that is in any way
called into question uh Ukraine as you
know uh the accession process is merits
based so it depends on the country
itself that wants to join the European
Union how fast it wants to reform and
progress towards the European Union and
the principles of the European Union and
here I must say um I've now accompanied
uh Ukraine throughout uh the last two
years intensively it is impressive to
see um the speed with which they are um
passing the reforms and the depth of the
reforms they are
applying um and for me it is
specifically impressive because this is
a country that is facing an Allon War so
despite this war they are deeply
committed and determined to move forward
and it's in their hands um what the
progress is concerned this actually goes
not only for Ukraine but for every
country that wants to join the European
Union and what could be felt um during
the last 18 to 20 months is that there
is a deep understanding in the region
that is this is a decisive time you have
to choose sides there are no gray zones
anymore and therefore I'm also impressed
by all the other countries that want to
join the European Union about the the
enlargement report is about them how
much they uh increase their ambition and
the speed to progress uh in the reforms
that are necessary for um joining the
accession path um I wish it would not be
a war that triggered this but it is
impressive to see that these countries
very clearly choose sides of democracy
the rule of law and peace and stability
uh to your second question I've made the
experience um that we had a very an
excellent cooperation during the last
six month a very solid work and work
that has been of high quality and very
much consistent and this is an excellent
example for the close cooperation of a
member State um that is president of the
council and the European
commission go with key key of
independent
Anastasia thank you so much uh I was
wondering how do you plan to get the
27th member State on board with
financial support for Ukraine before
January since you mentioned that that
would be a
priority would you
address this a very good this a very
good uh question uh but and you can
count on us to explain to you when we
will have convinced the 27 member states
will explain to you how we how we did
now more more seriously uh we are
determined to use all the possible
arguments and we engage uh with respect
for the various opinions on the table of
the European Council and we know that
getting United decis is always
challenging but this is an important
decision that we need to make and I
think the debate that we had yesterday
was also an occasion maybe to better
understand what could be some tools what
could be some arguments uh then uh that
that we will use uh in the days in the
weeks to come to prepare uh the next uh
European council
meeting
Tamar georan TV company ravit first of
all thank you Madame President Mr
President Mr Prime Minister for your
supporting for this historic decision uh
this is very important achievement for
Georgia what will be your message to
thousands of Georgia who are now just
now celebrating this decision and what
will be your advice for the next step
question for all of you thank
you two things
firstly when last night just after we
had taken the decision I had very quick
phone calls from president zalinski from
Maya Sandu and
Z
and and Iraq
ABI that will probably remain one of the
most emotional times on a personal level
for me um because at that time I was
saying on behalf of all the colleagues
under the table we have done this we
have taken this step we're opening up a
perspective which is fundamental because
it will change the face of the European
Union for the coming years for the
coming decades but it will also change
the reality of the qu countries in
question so the first message is of
course congratulations we're really
happy that we were able to take this
decision second message now let's work
quickly all of us together let's roll up
our sleeves let's make the necessary
steps and reforms and uh let's make this
European Union that we all
share um uh a success and let's uh share
these common values within the European
continent basically it is
congratulations and keep up the good
work you you are Europe we want you to
join the European Union and let's work
together I would add profit the momentum
because nowadays In This Very inter you
know this this
International um complexity that we are
living in to have a positive Horizons as
the one
that the people in Georgia in mova and
also in Ukraine are um having I think is
is quite important so I think it's first
of all profit that momentum and go for
the reforms that would allow at the end
of the day to enlarge the European Union
to these very important three countries
betri it's in the
middle thank you very much uh I think I
will take the opportunity to ask my
question
Spanish my first question for president
Michelle um with in with three months in
March will there need to be decisions
taken by the 27 once again in the
intergovernmental conference and to
agree the negotiations with uh Ukraine
and the framework for them how do you
intend to do that do you think that
Victor Oran is likely to leave the room
again and then a question for president
felion if I may uh a number of MEPS and
members of the opposition in
Spain have said that in recent times
there's a serious concern in Europe
about the political situation and the
rule of law and I'd be Ed to hear if you
compare the situation with what is
described in Brussels in respect of of
Hungary and Poland I'd be interested to
hear whether you feel that those
comparisons are accurate and whether
there are real grounds of concern in
Brussels is there concern regarding the
political situation and the rule of law
in Spain F first element you know that
the the principle in the European
Council we need to decide by unanimity
and it must remain the the principle but
yesterday we succeeded to make a
decision despite the fact that for one
member state was not possible to
formally support but we succeed to
convince not to oppose and not to make
impossible for the others to make a
United decision and this was a very uh
important step F first element the next
challenge is very clear the next
challenge this is the review of the
multiannual framework including the
financial path for Ukraine as well as
the other priorities that we have agreed
on and then indeed based on the
preparation by the European Commission
the member states will have to to to
assess and to make a decision for the
the start of the igc but we have a few
weeks a few months maybe a few months
will be needed to work seriously to
prepare and I think that we need to
prepare very well so that we have
powerful objective arguments uh that
will allow us uh again to make decisions
and to get United on this important Next
Step very general uh for all 20 27
member states um of course uh the
European commission is the guardian of
the treaty and in our daily work we work
on different files to make sure um that
uh the rules are uh respected for all 27
member states also is very clearly we
have full Trust In Our member states and
this is the basis and the foundation of
the work and the cooperation we have
together AFP so second third row
actually
you um I have a question first for
European commission president Ura V
Deion so there was this promise of the
50 billion EUR in financial aid and
Ukraine has just urged the EU to unlock
that money The Hope was that they would
get that money in this Summit now I'm
hearing from both yourself and uh
European Council president sha Michelle
that at the next Summit you'll look at
perhaps other ways now what I want to
know is what will you do differently
that you couldn't do now and do you feel
that you've let Ukraine down because
these promises were made and for
European Council council president sha
Michelle I really want to go into it you
say you're extremely confident about
supporting Ukraine with financial means
I'd like to know what makes you so
extremely confident that you will get
this so first of all the 50 billion are
for the period of four years that is
very important to make that clear um and
we have been working hard on the
financing for UK crin in every tranch so
also those tranches that have been
dispersed in the past this was always
hard work um because of course you
always need a broad consensus now in
detail uh in the coming days we will
release the last 1.5 billion euros for
Ukraine uh for this year that have been
agreed in the so-called MFA mcroof
financial assistance for 2023 so there's
a dispersement in the next days of 1.5
billion um this will help Ukraine
Finance their needs for the beginning of
the year 2024 this is important to build
a small um but important bridge and then
um as I said uh we have uh we will use
the time before the European Council
either we have an agreement by 27 or we
will have worked on Alternatives that we
can then make operational uh when the
time comes uh for this next Council uh
for us is very important there is a
consistent predictable and reliable
funding for Ukraine it's important for
Ukraine but it's important also for the
business environment and the
investors I I I repeat it I'm very
confident uh why because the starting
point is the following since yesterday
we have the support the stone support
expressed by 26 uh leaders to to to
fulfill on our promise and with another
starting point which is this uh what we
call the the nego Box the the the last
uh proposal which was agreed by 26
member states it means that in
comparison with some other European
Council uh we will start the meeting
knowing that 26 member states are
supporting uh the same goals the same
priorities including a package of 50
billions for Ukraine for the next four
years is my first point and my second
point I don't intend to enter into the
technical details but we have uh various
tools available to make sure that we'll
be able to uh fulfill our promise thank
you very much we'll close up the here
the press conference thank you have a
nice
weekend